are you guys doing
good good how are you steve nice to see
you nice to see both of you uh first
you guys both did such an excellent job
in this um
what is it like making the only movie
about 2020
in 2020. a privilege you know like it
was um
i was very excited about making this
film you know because
of all those things because it really
represented a lot of things that
not only i was going through but i felt
that other people were going through and
and the circumstances they were going
through and then
there was this kind of you know there's
obviously the kind of personalized
elements of that
and the emotion the anxiety the
uncertainty and then there was this sort
of fantastical element to it as well
which
which really i felt uplifting you know
and i felt kind of very hopeful there
was a hopeful side of this
of this film um that um that really
impacted me and i and i and i i sort of
um
i kind of needed it you know in a way
and so i was
i was very happy to go on the on the
journey and and with the hope that
other people have that experience as
well i just felt
incredibly grateful um you know the
thing is when you're a working actor
um i'm always aware of the fact that
there's a lot of actors who aren't
working and this year that was just more
true than ever
so i was i was even more appreciative
that i was a working actor
in 2020 it seemed like that i wasn't
gonna get to say those words
um but i just thought and what that
meant to me
was it gave it allowed me to put my
emotions and there were a lot of them in
this past year
to to use and to give them a purpose
and to share them with people and in the
sharing of them hopefully
allowing people a chance to recognize
some of themselves in that
in them and then the ultimate hope
that they would feel connection and less
alone and um
and yeah and and so uh so just what
she would have said i think privilege is
really is really the right word
one of the things i think is fascinating
about this movie is that they came up
with it in july you were filming in
september
it doesn't make sense how good steven's
script is in that limited time frame
but you essentially you guys were making
the fir you were making a first draft of
a movie
without the time to like sort of nickel
and dime every word
can you sort of talk about just jumping
into the fire and saying effort
well if you're working with steve knight
i think
yeah thing you know it was just he was
like he had to put
like even wherever it is coming from you
know
his sort of inspiration as it flies out
of him
you know and onto the page it sits you
know and you
feel like these characters are making
sense and and actually it's one of those
things that as you start to uncover it
you realize they're making really a
profound sense you know
one of the things that i love about this
film is that i think that the
relationship
is feels really genuine to me i really
understand
why these people are connected and why
they are then having
some they're in a sort of shaky
situation and what the potential is for
them to figure it out you know so
uh and i think that all of that just
sort of poured out of steve and i think
that
in any kind of endeavor like this the
first thing is always the script and
i think he's just very very just a very
very gifted man
it's funny that there's some there are
some scripts that you go in there
and you and you give suggestions and
there's rewrites and there's this and
there's that
this one you know doug and i one of the
first conversations we had was
i don't we really shouldn't change one
word we shouldn't
we shouldn't mess with this this is one
of those ones that you just trust
and that became part of the uh
just part of the nature of the thing of
it was to not overthink and to just dive
in
you know and um and that and i felt that
way with
with all aspects of it you just had to
trust that each choice was the right one
and if it wasn't
if we had time we would go back and try
something else
and um but but it's it's it's really
astonishing
what stephen knight was able to do with
that first draft i mean
the first 90 pages can you imagine that
just arriving in your inbox after
having lived through the first six
months of the pandemic and reading those
lines and just saying i know this isn't
me but god
i know this feeling it was it was
remarkable
sure as i said you guys did a great job
um good luck with the rest of your speed
dating
thank you so much for your time thank
you guys take care